charles huet président de la carf
française auteur du guide des produits
made in emploie éditions du puits fleuri
bonsoir à vous charles est à vos côtés
yves dubief président de l'union des
industries textiles pdg de l'entreprise
tintoret merci à vous également il du
bief merci d'être avec nous alors je le
disais à l'instant à cette liste du
coronavirus qui a mis en lumière notre
dépendance cruel uns aux autres
relocaliser une partie de notre
industrie s'avoue être désormais une
priorité charles huet
c'est une priorité aujourd'hui mais
comme ça l'était déjà ça l'est toujours
pour tout pays c'était une urgence déjà
depuis quelques temps ça fait maintenant
depuis depuis trente ans que la france
se désindustrialise depuis 2000 on a
perdu un million d'emplois industriels
on s'aperçoit que c'est très utile en
période de crise comme les industriels
textiles nous l'ont montré
quand les chaînes d'approvisionnement
international sont rompues eh bien on
est bien content d'avoir des industriels
et des usines des ateliers sur notre
territoire pour nous approvisionner en
max en masque ou en gel hydro alcoolique
mais c'est aussi extrêmement utile pour
créer de la richesse des emplois qui
sont disséminés dans tout le territoire
pour financer notre modèle social pour
réduire notre empreinte carbone
si on veut vraiment passer aux actes
aussi sur ce sujet donc réindustraliser
c'est nécessaire parce que ça impacte
tous les grands enjeux du moment alors
même constat
yves dubief il faut faire revenir
machines et outils sur le territoire
c'est un voeu pieux ou vous sentez qu'il
ya désormais une vraie volonté politique
de réduire réindustrialisation de la
france
je crois que il ya une telle volonté
puisque vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
la baisse des impôts de production de
dim de 10 milliards en 2021 de 10
milliards en 2022 qui permet aux
entreprises donc d'améliorer leur
compétitivité et leur prix de revient
industriels et de pouvoir donc se battre
beaucoup plus efficacement avec les
produits qui viennent en europe qui
peuvent venir de très prochain du
portugal ou de belgique d'un peu plus
loin deux plats turquie ou du maroc et
d'encore plus loin de l'asie donc c'est
ce geste que annoncé conjointement le
premier ministre et bruno le maire est
tout à fait favorable à la
réindustrialisation et en tant
qu'industriel textile et président de la
fédération textile nous nous sommes
battus puisque j'étais l'auteur d'un
rapport avec jacques le pape sur les
impôts de production il ya deux ans
justement on va écouter ce passage dans
vos qu'elle vous faites allusion bruno
le maire qui évoque cette baisse des
impôts de production a coûté produire en
france se voit moins cher les impôts de
production baisseront massivement de 20
milliards d'euros d'ici deux ans notre
objectif est de relocaliser et
développer l'industrie en france charles
maetz et c'est précisément ce qu'il faut
faire c'est un bon début où ça va
vraiment faire avancer la situation
selon vous non c'était une attente
importante parce qu'effectivement c'est
un élément de manque de compétitivité
coût crucial pour les industriels
français
le sujet maintenant c'est son montant sa
viabilité
son financement et puis le reste des
mesures qui viendront compléter sa je
crois qui ces dix milliards c'est
important mais je pense qu'il faudrait
quatre fois plus pour pour revenir à la
moyenne européenne d'impôt de production
il faut accompagner sa aussi de
simplification massive des impôts donc
forte investissement aussi dans la
formation la formation professionnelle
en particulier
et puis il ya un sujet d'achats publics
de mettre de passage à l'acte d'achat de
manière générale de tous les français
ce qu'on ne peut pas tout attendre de
l'état mais c'est un bon geste
il se retire pour redonner de l'air
financière financier à nos industriels
pour qu'ils retrouvent la compétitivité
maintenant il faut que les consommateurs
passent aux actes et soutiennent de
manière sonnante et trébuchante ces
industriels qui se sont dévoués pour
notre santé ces derniers mois il du bief
selon vous les consommateurs eux sont
prêts à acheter français sont prêts à
donner ce coup de pouce peut-être
parfois payer légèrement plus cher
attente on leur demande ils disent
qu'ils sont prêts à 80 90 % de passer à
l'acte d'acheter français
et quand ils sont devant la caisse du
magasin ou ou sur l'application qui leur
permet d'acheter sur e-commerce
ils sont beaucoup moins nombreux donc
ces essais c'est toujours ça l'enjeu
c'est de leur démontrer que acheter
français c'est achetez local c'est de la
proximité c'est conforter l'emploi dans
l'industrie française sur l'ensemble du
territoire
et c'est aussi comme le disait monsieur
d'être un geste pour la planète puisque
les mesures qui sont en place en france
concernant l'environnement sont beaucoup
plus rigoureuse beaucoup plus forte et
beaucoup mieux appliqué et donc entre un
tee shirt ou un masque qui vient de
chine et le même produit produit sur le
territoire français la rejette car
bogues et les rejets de co2 sont deux à
huit ou un indice il déviait fait
d'accord avec ce diagnostic
évidemment d'accord évidemment d'accord
on oublie enfin on rappelle
insuffisamment le tous les impacts
effectivement écologique de consommer
local aujourd'hui
[Musique]
prétendre un engagement écologique en
étant habillé de pied en cap en produits
en textile importés ça me semble un
petit peu compliqué ça me semble pas
loin d'une tartufferie
au delà des normes très exigeantes en
matière environnementale au delà de la
proximité de la réduction de l'empreinte
carbone dues au transport
on a aussi un mix énergétique en france
effectivement qui est qui est le moins
carboné du monde et des normes de rejet
des deux produits chimiques par exemple
pour l'industrie textile qui sont les
plus drastiques du monde donc on partage
tous ces diagnostics maintenant le sujet
c'est de passer des paroles aux actes
les industriels les ateliers les
couturières
deux de ces baies l'industrie qui sont
répartis dans le monde de nos cantons ne
vivent pas de like de partage de tapes
dans le dos et de bienveillance elles
vivent de 2,2 d'outils de production
mais de carnet de commandes rempli qui
leur verseront des salaires donc voilà
l'état fait un premier geste important
ça va dans le bon sens il faut que ce
soit plus fort et pérenniser mais
maintenant c'est à tout un chacun de
prendre le relais on peut tous faire
quelque chose entre deux élections
présidentielles on va 150 fois faire les
courses
on a des proches à gâter dès noël à
fêter des anniversaires à fêter
il faut penser voilà nos industriels
textiles alimentaire maison tout saisi
mute
on peut faire peut on peut ré
industrialiser on peut tous le faire
lorsque parfois c'est pas si évident à
organiser les filières on va prendre un
exemple assez simple et très récents
dont on a évidemment beaucoup parlé
l'exemple des masques vous qui avez fait
partie justement il veut du bief de ces
entreprises qui se sont mobilisés très
vite pour fabriquer des masques
quand on a vu qu'on
on n'avait pas au début de l'épidémie de
coronavirus comment ça s'est passé
ou est-ce que vous en êtes aujourd'hui
dès la fin du mois de mars l'industrie
textile a fait preuve de son agilité et
de de son ca capacité de retournement
pour remettre en place une filière qui a
mobilisé vingt mille salariés en france
et un peu plus de 1000 entreprises et
qui ont permis de produire jusqu'à ces
derniers jours un peu plus de 100
millions de masques alors il ya
l'enthousiasmé ouest du début dans le
dans le climat sanitaire que l'on
connaissait il ya là le démarrage après
yal enthousiasme la machine s'emballe un
peu les commandes sont là et puis les
commandes de son un peu plus flou est en
réalité elles sont elles sont pas très
fermé on atterri un peu brutalement fin
mai début juin avec un des stocks
excédentaires de masques qui ont frôlé
les 70 80 millions pour l'ensemble de
des acteurs du territoire français mais
qui ne faisait pas tout sur le
territoire français ici on regarde ce
qu'ils ont fabriqué totalement sur le
territoire français c'est une petite
quarantaine de millions de masques qui
étaient là en excédent aujourd'hui la
mission que guillaume gibbons et moi
même avons menées ont permis de réduire
ce nombre de 40 millions environ 22 23
millions donc c'est déjà un beau un beau
succès une bonne baisse mais il ya
encore donc un peu plus de 20 millions
de masques sur le territoire chez les
producteurs il y en a dans la grande
distribution et y en a chez tout un
chacun que ça soit le particulier qui en
a reçu de sa collectivité sa
collectivité territoriale de son
entreprise il y en a dans les
entreprises pour retenir les dix
semaines que préconise madame la
ministre a mené ce panier une hache est
donc tout ça c'est des dizaines et
dizaines de millions donc on est très
bien armés aujourd'hui pour tenir un
deuxième choc
merci en tout cas tous les deux charrues
est yves debien avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france